أنا السوسة ...سوسة  *** أنا السوسة ...سوسة
أنخر أنخر أسنانك ***  أسكن فيها مدسوسة
سوسة سوسة ...سوسة *** سوسة سوسة ...سوسة
هذا بيتى ما أحلاه *** أحفر أسفله وأعلاه
أسكن فيه آكل حلوى *** سكر سكر ما أشهاه
سوسة سوسة ...سوسة *** سوسة سوسة ...سوسة
ضرسي ضرسي آآي آآآي *** ألم يوجع لي خداي
تلك السوسة الشريرة *** توجعني تدمع عيناي
سوسة يا سوسة سوسة *** سوسة يا سوسة سوسة
أنا السوسة يسعدني *** في سنك أحفر أبني
أسنان حلوة وجميلة *** ستصير جميعا سكني
سوسة سوسة ...سوسة *** سوسة سوسة ...سوسة
أسناني آآه تؤلمني *** حتى الراحة تحرمني
سوسة تنخر في ضرسي *** في نومي آآه تزعجني
سوسة يا سوسة سوسة ***سوسة يا سوسة سوسة
أنا السوسة ...سوسة *** أنا السوسة ...سوسة
أنخر أنخر أسنانك *** أسكن فيها مدسوسة
سوسة سوسة ...سوسة *** سوسة سوسة ...سوسة
قد كنت بالفعل كسولة *** عن غسل أسنانك مشغولة
أهملت نظافتها حتى *** أنخرها و أحفر بسهولة
سوسة سوسة ...سوسة *** سوسة سوسة ...سوسة
قد حان وقت فرشاتي *** أحملها عقب الوجبات
أغسل وازيل السوسة *** وستبقى إحدى عاداتي
آه من تلك الفرشاة *** هدمت بيتي في لحظات
لم تترك شيئا آكله *** كم أكره تلك الفرشاة
سوسة يا سوسة ...سوسة